hello everybody my name is
[Music]
also known as markiplier and welcome to
lunch lady now this is typically a game
that you would play with four other
friends or three other friends and you'd
have proximity voice and phasmophobia
and all that stuff but i'm alone right
now and i'm like
i'm probably gonna play this on tuesday
with the boys so expect another episode
with them if this proves to be fun if
this isn't fun then i won't do that
so i'm gonna go up by myself against
what's known as the lunch lady and
someone tells me that the lunch lady
lixie and put air quotes by my head
so i'm about the lunch lady isn't gonna
be so nice look at the shoulders on that
guy
look at the freaking shoulders on him
my god that is the perfect male form
oh my god they all got the shoulders
oh
well
not to be asian but i am and i think he
is
yeah probably
oh my god
that's kind of ominous
okay here we go
i really have no idea what this game is
about or what the objective is
difficulty normal
steal 10 pages full of test answers for
your school's final exams
all right then
so slender the 10 pages it is
i should play that game again
like the original oh it's running like a
turd hang on one second
that should work better there we go
that's the good stuff all right so uh
also a little bit of baldi's basics too
right no breaking the fourth wall in the
halls
man
okay let me just get immersed into the
atmosphere i always start these off a
little too rambo
like see an amp up the atmosphere
like really amp it up
more
more
that's enough thank you i got a med kit
whatever that means
and why does the lunch lady care if i
steal
the
test dancers
so why are they all in different places
and why is the lighting so uh
what am i looking at what am i looking
at
okay maybe this is gonna be a little
spookier than i thought it was gonna be
okay
why is it drafty
in the rooms
why does this wind whip through here
whoa
is that
that's not me
that's not me lunch lady
is it you
say you lunch lady
lunch lady
lunch lady
lunch lady
okay i don't like this
officially i'm entering the i don't like
this territory drinks is that a question
mark
okay
something tells me i don't want the
hallway b key
good god
yeah no this would be terrifying with
friends
yeah no this is a
why do the footsteps sound like they're
coming right behind me hello
i don't like that okay hallway eight oh
i got a finals answer page
i've done it
at least the first page okay good
well that that bodes goodly for me
that bodes very goodly i'm not goodly
bowed
who
why
where
oh way b hallway see yeah i know
just trying to see if there's anything
over here before i go into the hallways
because it seems like the footy steps
are good
what
don't you dare
don't you freaking dare
don't you freaking dare
dawn you freaking there don't you're
freaking there don't you freaking there
okay i told you
and you listened
good you really i don't know why they
did this
hey
how you doing how are you doing how are
you doing
great i'm in the bathroom oh good got
becky now
i wonder if it's like a strategy to get
all the keys first and then make your
way down to the hallways i would assume
so but then i can only assume from here
as i literally know nothing
medkit okay medkit suggests that if i
get caught i won't die immediately or
else it's something where i would go
down and the friends that i don't have
would pick me up
therefore i would die so let's not test
the theory no matter what okay i have
hallway c key
but that's where i saw
her i don't know why they did this oh
no can you see me are you coming for me
you're better than yeah okay
what is it
why did it look like she was in a
cheerleaders outfit
hey
how you doing oh
goody
you see me
let's see this [ __ ] i'm gonna
show you my true speed
is this one
staircase key of course of course oh
that was terrifying also what was that
oh my god oh no i got it i got it you
tried to stop me you i'm gonna play
bring around rosie around your posies
and poses
oh i'm not here
i'm here i'm not here i'm here i'm not
here
i'm not here i'm not here hi oh now
wow now
oh no no no no no no thank you no thank
you no thank you ah oh ow
wow what the hell did you do to me oh no
please please no no okay are you gonna
teabag me
[Music]
i'm using a med kit maybe
[Music]
i'm using a med kit
[Music]
maybe i should be quieter
[Applause]
[Music]
ow
i'm dead
i'm dead i'm literally dead i have died
the lunch lady killed me
i'm a freaking deadman all right let's
try this swimming haul
let's give me give me a little
normal i guess is the easiest all right
let's try this all right lunch lady you
and me we're gonna dance we're gonna
tussle
tussle with a muscle
you look pretty strong if you were
taller you know
maybe i might be into that
all right so now i'm in a pool hall of
some of this
doesn't look like a pool
okay
i'm assuming noise is probably a
mechanic that i should be worried about
i'm not going to do anything about it
but i am going to be worried about it
cafeteria key okay
thank you
very ominous ooh there's music in the
pool hall why is there music in the pool
hall
whoa
what the hell was it
hi
i'll take that don't know why the finals
are all here
hi
this is
fine
hello hey
i'm doing great
i'm doing real good i got two
i think i got two last then
i guess i'll just be methodical about
this
boy i wish i had friends
boy it's so sad that i'm so lonely hey
three
hey we're doing good we're doing good
today
we're doing real good
okay good good good good
why why heartbeat
oh no
oh god oh it opened oh it opened oh it
shouldn't have opened wait it opened can
you get up here am i safe i'm safe i'm
safe for now i'm safe okay i'm okay
i'm okay
not safe
not safe not safe not safe not safe turn
this off turning this off you can't see
me
you can't see me you have no idea where
i am
i want to go down and around
down and around
down and around you can't see me can't
hear me
okay
am i i don't see
[Music]
oh okay no
no
no
no no
okay
easy peasy see if you don't make too
much noise and turn off your light
maybe you might be avoided
which is what i was
what i did
you up
this office
okay but if you're up that means you
can't get down this too quickly man i'm
free to do whatever i want
for the moment
oh
well that's probably not good all right
it's probably not good all right it's
probably not good oh you're up there
okay you're fine i'm fine you're fine
i'm fine you don't know where i is
you don't know where i is you have no
idea where i is
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yes oh okay that's four
oh god
oh god okay okay okay okay okay
closest good
i'm in the cafeteria isn't this like
where the lunch lady would be at her
strongest
don't like it
i don't like it
i like it less
i like it much only
okay
i'm just gonna try to make my way out
here
i'm sorry
i'm sorry what you
lunch lady hey um this the meatloaf this
is the mystery mate i should not be in
here why did i come in here why would
anyone have come in here
i don't know but i think i think she's
on the other side of the school by now
so i should be okay at least for the
moment exploring this area
okay that's all for the cafeteria i
haven't found many keys
i need the nursery key
okay that's i see okay there's a key i
got the nursery room key that is exactly
the key that i was hoping for okay so
this is good that means that when i get
down
there those are the nurses room okay
cool cool cool cool cool
rub it up cool cool
mega cool
hugely cool at least with this map i
feel like i can play ring around the
rosie okay close close closer you'll
never know
you'll never know
you'll never know god there's a there's
probably exactly ten
isn't there i gotta come the entire
goddamn map
look
why is there a full-on hospital in this
place
what happened in this swimming hall
where's the swimming pool
okay
god i have found no oh
don't know why the test answers are over
there
okay that's halfway through i'm never
gonna be
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] push it
yes no maybe so
shush
[Applause]
that's probably fine that's probably
fine that's probably fine it's not fine
it is not fine it is not fine
hey hey hey hey
hey oh hey oh i got another one
could have sworn that i saw this area
before so i don't know how that just
gave me
okay okay okay okay i think i got away a
little bit at least oh it's in here
nothing oh finals this
oh you're pissed ain't you oh you're
pale yes
oh hey okay but you're down there so i'm
fine i'm gonna go around the other way
i'm gonna climb up that side i've got
seven of ten
seven of ten
one two three four five six seven
of
which means that i'm doing pretty good
okay
no oh shoot
oh shoot
what is that pool key i would love to
know where the pool was
i think the pool hall must be just
directly below me because i think down
the hallway to the left was cafeteria so
right must be the pool hall okay
what did i do
no
oh
are you kidding me
no
no no no no ring around my rosies oh my
god my posies
no
no
no
no no you did whatever you did
don't don't don't don't don't don't
don't no oh my god
part of you
can you leave please can you leave okay
i don't know how much time i have so i'm
guess i'm just guessing occasionally
she uh catches my scent
and can charge at me
yeah you go oh yeah you go that way you
freaking idiot you freaking dumb ass you
dummy
you big dumbass
you big floppy dumbass
you big gun going i'm going
[Music]
so that's a mark against uh staying in
one place for a long time definitely
don't do that it's okay i don't think
she knows about exercise
she'll never find me in the pool
come on come on
someone must have left answers in the
shower
is that answers no
answers no
answers no i really don't know how she
got me either did she throw like a
frying pan or something like that oh
this is just
just a ring around the pool isn't it
really nothing
i'm really not gonna
oh
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay there's an uppy but
let me check the other locker room first
because i might be able to find
i can find
oh okay there was an upbeat i'm gonna go
the uppie i'm gonna go on the uppie
we're going up we're going up wherever
the uppy is i'm going up he
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah this feels good
this feels good there's got to be one up
here
there's got to be one more up here oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay which way you going which way you
going huh
okay you know you know now you know you
think you know you do not know you do
not know you do not know you don't know
you know not
you know nothing you know nothing you
know nothing i've only got nine of ten
damn it there must have been one in this
there must have been one no there's a
toilet there must have been one there
must have been one maybe in the opening
of the other area over there maybe on
the other side over here
there must have been one there must have
been
must've been unless i missed it
somewhere else in this goddamn map which
is entirely possible door there was
another door oh no i thought that was it
why was there another door over there
turlets turlets turlets turlets
goddammit
oh goddamn
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you coming this way
oh [ __ ] oh god damn it oh god damn it oh
god damn it oh god damn it okay that was
oh god damn okay oh that says ah that's
close to me behind me ah don't do it oh
[Music]
okay i thought there might have been
another door on the other side over here
like there was on that side it looks
like i just missed it somewhere in the
opening area i must have there must be
like a door on the bottom floor that i
have not been in which is entirely
believable
i'm just going for it going forward
going forward
screw you
screw you
yeah yeah
i was in here yeah i was in there
definitely was that oh god damn it and
goddamn me oh where could it be where
could it be i have no idea i do not know
ah
frick
frickin dick
frick my dick
every dick frick all of the dicks freak
a dick oh freaking duck
oh muck my fruck
let's go here
god damn it
kid
oh
i'm free
you know 9 out of 10 is good enough it's
still an a
90
it's a passing grade i should be happy
i should be happy i should be very happy
but i'm not happy i'm not happy at all
i'm going back in the nurses area i
don't know if there's another med kit
for me to steal
your service
i don't know about a test though
didn't see no test though unless i did
and then you guys are pointing it out to
me and i i can't help that right now
i just gotta recheck now which sucks ass
unless it was in this opening first area
maybe
i know that there was like a
room back here
no maybe on the other side i don't know
if i went to the other side no the other
side is a staircase
i can't leave yet why can't i leave yet
why can't i
why couldn't i god i'm backtracking on
all the places
finding nothing
oh god oh god please don't be up top you
up top no you're not okay
okay that's fine
that's not where i am
i was in here
didn't see anything in here oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay you're coming uh [ __ ] oh you're
going the exact way that i need to go
okay i'm gonna run around the other way
i'm going for the long route but it's a
safe way to go as only she actually goes
upstairs
if she doesn't go upstairs i'm in big
trouble
which way are you going
you coming upstairs
which way you go which way you go which
way which way which way
you uppy or you downey
downy i'm sure good call me good call me
thanks me i think i'm in the clear i
think i'm gonna win this i think i got
this i think the lunch lady is about to
eat my ass well hopefully not eat my ass
that's the objective is not to eat my
ass and i'm good
i did it who needs friends
i escaped i did it
squishy so that is lunch lady that was
pretty spooky it was pretty stressful i
don't like the whole collection mechanic
but it worked well here and i bet with
friends it would be even creepier
because hearing them screaming down the
halls would be quite delightful i don't
even know what she'd be like on insane
but probably would be able to clear out
your whole team pretty quickly if you
want to see more videos like this that i
have played with bob and wade go check
out phasmophobia linked in the
description or just go to my channel and
search for phasmaphobia or youtube
phasmaphobia markiplier you can always
multiple ways you can find my videos
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you